we've just learned something to cast the
boys head count fan and we're alive at
comic-con as we count down to their show
premiering by the way how is the
comic-con experience been for you guys
so far really don't say the panel's and
it's been like party central for you
come on
okay now this show is based on
superheroes or bad guys and then there's
the boys who are the good guys so who
are the superheroes who are the bad guys
I'm a suit suit I'm not gonna raise my
hand on her way it's on I managed okay
explain the premise Oh evil won a lot of
money we we are part of the most
important company in the world basically
Amazon Facebook Google all in one and
these are the most powerful people there
is Disney in real life too yeah in real
life too you have a 10% of rank and then
along comes this crew of folks who
change the game right Karl that's your
that's your right with the boys we're a
vigilante group we've got no superpowers
and it's our job to take these guns down
with with no superpowers no shield house
she's a super voice yeah I heard that
you guys have a lot of fun on the set
messing with the superheroes is that
true
even off the side let me show you what I
have here
[Applause]
take your characters called and he has
his own calendar Thanks haha look at
February 2020 everyone had a month I get
here it's all deep all the deep yeah
honey what do you guys think of the
deeps calendar how's that going I
clearly had too much fun mber January
when you're shot so it's interesting you
guys haven't premiered yet but you have
a season 2 already how does that work
somebody explain that to me yeah yeah
yeah that's great man we've got a great
team and it's it's hard to get the
chemistry sick right and we've got it
we've got it right in terms of
personality and everything so you know I
think everyone I got to be pretty real
but I will never a wrong feels very
fortunate to have another crack at it
and you know that's the great thing
about TV you know it's not just the one
and done hopefully we get to come back
and do more fun stuff and we got a great
writing team that's coming up with great
fresh materials we're lucky what about
the physicality of these roles I mean
you guys get it in don't you yeah yeah
like the girls as well yeah it's fine I
love it I love him more than I expected
I've never done any type of fighting
training before and it was just like
it's sort of like a dance it's like
choreography and you learn it and as
soon as it's ingrained in your head it's
so fun was it just like and we have an
awesome stunt coordinator who like
prepped us for it and they're badass I
love it all the women on the show us how
many tunes not here today
yeah you guys train together do all
everybody train together no yeah my
bootys of the bunch let's say the only
training I got was how to get hit and
have to flail around everyone else
that's the superhero training my
character he doesn't really know how to
fight and he gets his ass kicked a lot
so there we go so you learned how to
fall learn how to fall yes fall well has
anybody gotten hurt ah yes
early on while filming well coming
that he accidentally hit me during a
scene and it was the greatest reaction
because you know it's supposed to be you
know it's a fake hit but he did it and
then Laz poor lass he was like oh my god
I'm so like it was an immediate apology
but I'm still some dude I love it broke
skin he had a big night
it was terrible kept going would you and
that's the tape thing yeah yeah this is
um this comic on earth is based on comic
books so have you guys did any of you
read the comic books at a time did
anybody have a chance to digest them and
know about it beforehand what do you
know what did you know about
I mean Kripke called me Eric Kripke our
showrunner called me and he was like he
said them my way and he was like read it
so you can grasp the foundation of this
show that we're doing because I feel
like it's kind of cool to read the
source material because a informs you
but also it got me excited because it's
dark and gritty and crazy and I just
made me aware of how much we were gonna
push the envelope which got me sites
that's it you couldn't put the comic
book director strain so today we keep
the spirit in the soul and show you
grammars and all great characters and
you sort of just take some of the edge
off you have an edgy show it's not a kid
show but it is also something that is
allowed to be on TV yeah exactly
has anybody walked the floor here at
comic-con yet yeah yeah yeah yeah you
will I will
but it'll be fun
and by the way it could be eerie that
next year you come here and there a
bunch of people dressed like you're
superheroes like Halloween I'm looking
forward to people coming in deep
Calendar custard what is it like having
such as the MEP SS Robin it would have
flavors that bring to this project well
you definitely feel you know the same
that sensibility of you know never take
yourself too seriously you know or any
of these characters and and the world
that all of our characters collectively
live in is so ridiculous
that that you can't you know but but
that that's that's the magic of our of
our humor smoke smoke smoke flower how
much fun is it in doing it and being
with this cast and are you imparting any
wisdom on these youngsters me now I've
been partying the wisdom of making a lot
of money different streaming is very
different than anything else it how how
is it different than a movie or anything
else or does it feel the same um well I
think it's amazing because you get to
tell stories that are more complicated
and have a longer life and um I I love
it I'd never do a movie again
[Laughter]
[Music]
when you going between shaft and the
boys no one followed the other
immediately like right two days in
between did you bring these shafts swag
to the boy no I mean the characters is
so vastly different like yeah you know
JJ was like Timmy and shy and like
nervous all the time and in a train it's
like this obnoxious self-centered really
boast rest's outgoing it's like very
totally different gear I couldn't I
couldn't bring Jay data a train Samuel
Jackson's shaft a train like that that
works goes to Gossip Girl reboot yeah I
mean I'm not a we're not gonna be a part
of it but yeah is there any do you want
to have you don't want any hand in and
you were kind of like guys I mean you
know get the buzz head now I moved on
man he's not come back as a father
gallis brilliant no projects after this
period what do you guys start shooting
season two any secrets that you can tell
us or is there anything you're gonna
announce at comic-con that I don't wanna
hear later no be like why did you a just
walk over there now
[Music]
he announced man like hi Akash isn't it
she's yeah yeah she's she's playing it
cool last carriage oh yeah I know the
strong female yeah another strong female
character we look forward to the rest of
the Kenneth outweigh these case this
one's going back only you know these
will have this
[Music]